arrêtez tout vous vous trompez et oui
car toutes les pierres ne se veulent pas
ou plutôt tous les minéraux ne sont pas
égaux vous connaissez l'échelle de moss
c'est l'allemand friedrich moche qui l'a
inventée en 1812 ce mec était
minéralogiste et fils de marchand l'aimé
bien rangé les cailloux dans des petites
boîtes
il a même imaginé une systématique des
minéraux en les rangeant par ordre
classe espèces genre tout ça comme line
et l'avait fait moins d'un siècle plus
tôt sur les êtres vivants je trouve ça
assez cool storybrooke pour pouvoir
reconnaître les minéraux il a même
développé sa propre échelle de dureté et
alors qu'est ce donc que la dureté je
vous vois venir bande de pervers c'est
physique
c'est une grandeur physique c'est la
mesure de la résistance à la pénétration
à l'origine c'était définit comme la
facilité ou la difficulté avec laquelle
on pouvait rayer un minéral donc plus il
est dur à rayer plus il est dur merci la
science ou plus il est facile à riez au
contraire et plus il est tendre et pour
pouvoir reconnaître les minéraux il nous
faut des instruments non à ce genre
d'instrument
bienvenue dans le musée de la torture
alors l'échelle se compose de dix
minéraux et allons pas comme des chevaux
fossilisés mais comme des minéraux de
référence qui sont numérotées de 1 à 10
alors en un
on m'a tout en bas le talk qui est donc
le plus tendre et en dise tout en haut
nous avons le diamant qui est le plus
dur le plus dur qu'on connaisse en tout
cas donc le principe c'est que chaque
libéral règne ceux qui sont en dessous
de lui si je prends ce quartz améthyste
de dureté 7 et se gypse de dureté 2 est
bien celui là va relayer celui ci comme
vous pouvez le voir l inverse ce n'est
pas vrai
logique ne peut pas non plus le rayer
parce que je suis pas un libéral par
contre je peux le rayer à l'ongle
[Musique]
regardez-moi ça au ballon ou super duo
petit bout et ça c'est parce que mon
ongle votre ongle notre hong à une
dureté de 2,5 à peu près donc
il peut briller tout ce qu'il ya en
dessous et pascal au dessus donc y ait
toujours un angle sur vous c'est
vachement pratique tutu c'est vrai je
dis beaucoup tutu ils déboulent métro
évidemment mon corps tout en vaut donc
j'en parle et le diamant peut uniquement
se faire rayer par un autre diamant
ça tombe vachement bien parce qu'on est
tous tellement riche qu'on a plusieurs
diamants chez nous on peut se permettre
de le rayer en plus on peut aussi servir
d'outil donc j'ai parlé de l'ongle mais
il ya aussi une pièce en cuivre par
exemple
du verre ou un couteau donc vous l'aurez
compris ça marche par comparaison c'est
ce qu'on appelle une échelle ordinale
vous avez un caillou standard vous
essayez de trouver ce que c'est vous
pouvez essayer de le lécher comme on a
vu précédemment mais si vous tenez à la
vie vous pouvez essayer de le rayer
d'abord donc avec votre ongle par
exemple et si jamais c'est votre oncle
qui perd vous savez qu'il a une dureté
supérieur à 2,5 et au fur et à mesure
comme ça vous pouvez agir par
discrimination et essayer à peu près
d'identifier autres cailloux jetés
or donc oui parce qu'on connaît pas de
minérale naturelle qui soit plus dur que
le diamant à l'heure actuelle en tout
cas il me semble même si tous les six
mois il ya un peu des rigolos qui
s'amusent à annoncer oui on a détrôné le
diamant et tous genres la carmélite
hésite en décembre 2018 mais chaque fois
bah en fait non pour la kermesse basit
en particulier je vous renvoie vers
l'excellente vidéo deviennent l'original
ou alors si c'est des minéraux qui sont
plus dur que le diamant ben c'est pas
vraiment des minéraux c'est des
matériaux synthétiques
donc du coup bah si c'est pas naturel ça
compte pas d'orage les chimistes
alors il va sans dire que l'ensemble de
l'ouvragé est une critique de la pensée
de heidegger qui entre nous est un gros
con mais qu'est-ce que je fais là mais
c'est pas pour autant qu'il ya que c'est
dur tu es là qui existe un lien a plein
d'autres c'est une échelle continue nous
par exemple vous avez la massane ipsca
une dureté de 9.5 donc elle va caresser
niche entre le corindon qu'on utilise
pour le papier de verre et le diamant
mais je sais bien ce que vous brillez de
me demander alors pourquoi pourquoi donc
les tous les minéraux ont pas la même
dureté et ben ça c'est une bonne
question et je suis allée la poser à un
vrai procès parties
bonjour pierre pierre vous êtes
directeur du lobby des minéraux et
amateurs d'andouillette alors je vous
arrête tout de suite ici on s'assoit sur
les tables voilà c'est mieux nous avons
enquêté nous avons pu nous procurer des
documents d'une source confidentielle
wikipédia comme vous pouvez le voir ici
ces lignes nous montre que tous les
minéraux non pas la même dureté est ce
que vous confirmer ces informations
comment vous justifier ces inégalités ce
que vous comptez faire quelque chose
un silence éloquent
en gros ça dépend de la structure
cristalline de notes minérales donc
selon la nature des liaisons entre les
atomes
si les liaisons sont fortes par exemple
des liaisons covalentes avec les atomes
tous partagent deux électrons entre ben
ce moment là on aura plus de mal à
casser ces liaisons pour faire des
microsillons d'adhérer sûrs quoi c'est
logique donc par exemple le quartz et le
diamant ont des structures vraiment bien
rigides en 3d avec des liaisons
covalentes donc c'est difficile de les
casser
vous avez aussi un autre facteur c'est
la taille des cristaux le quartz par
exemple il fait des gros cristaux bien
formés tout ça donc mastoc en échange
vous avez aussi l'argile qui est aussi
un minéral mais pour le coup il est
constitué de plein de petits cristaux
microscopiques qui vont s'agréger donc
là pour le coup c'est beaucoup plus
facile de se frayer un chemin entre les
cristaux c'est comme si vous essayez de
graver votre nom dans la neige ou dans
du sable avec votre index c'est beaucoup
plus facile que de le faire sur un mur
de béton par exemple mais comme bien
souvent cette échelle de moss aussi a
ses limites
la première limite c'est que ben les
minéraux sont une fabrication artisanale
c'est industrielle donc la composition
va varier très légèrement d'un minéral à
l'autre pour une même espèce et sa basse
et engendre des duretés qui peuvent
varier aussi très légèrement a réussi
notre minérale est un peu érodée en
surface ou oxydés avec le contact de
l'air dans ce cas-là ça aussi ça peut
influer sur sa dureté points furent
jédir influent ou maintenant voilà nous
pour rester dans l'esprit musée de la
torture on conseille de casser votre
minérale pour avoir une surface bien
neuf bien fraîche avant de le rayer mais
surtout ce que je trouve hyper
intéressant c'est que certains minéraux
ont une dureté variable selon la
direction dans laquelle on les raye dit
qu'ils sont anisotrope ça veut dire
qu'ils n'ont pas les mêmes propriétés
physiques dans toutes les directions de
l'espace
je trouve ça vraiment hyper classe un
exemple frappant c'est celui du dix ten
qui a une dureté de 8 dans un sens et de
4 dans l'autre
donc ça ça dépend de la nature des
liaisons qui lie les atomes entre dans
un sens ils défoncent sa mère le quartz
et dans l'autre au contraire un simple
coup d'apatite est pas il est en pls
la dernière critique c'est que l'échelle
n'est pas linéaire donc la dureté entre
les premiers minéraux de l'échelle est
plus proche que la dureté des derniers
minéraux de l'échelle vous voyez sur ce
graphe
le diamant n'est même plus dedans ça
c'est un peu ma top pour une échelle de
référence pour modèle pour nos modes
pour moderniser cette échelle et des
scientifiques ont proposé des
alternatives
donc on a d'autres échelles de dureté en
général c'est des mesures qui sont
effectués en pressant le minéral avec
une pointe ou une bille qui peut être en
acier qui peut être en diamants par
exemple ça dépend et donc à partir de la
réponse du minéral
on arrive à en déduire sa dureté et
aussi d'autres paramètres physiques
qu'on peut mesurer comme le module de
compression ou le module de cisaillement
je vais pas entrer dans les détails
parce que la vie est bien trop courte
quoi qu'il en soit c'est quand même
vachement pratique notre échelle de
moche parce que ça nous permet d'aller
sur le terrain avec notre ongles et
notre couteau et comme ça on peut
identifier les minéraux qui croise notre
chemin c'est pour ça qu'elle est encore
aujourd'hui beaucoup utilisé à la fois
sur le terrain et enseigner aussi sur
les bancs de la fac
et c'est justement pour cette raison que
j'ai fait cette vidéo oui car
aujourd'hui j'ai besoin de vous tagro ce
concierge folle d'amour hausse quémander
tes caresses divine
c'est avec cette phrase que les
étudiants apprennent l'échelle de moss à
l'école depuis des milliards d'années
moi même c'est comme ça que je les ai
prises je sais pas ce que vous en pensez
je trouve ça absolument révoltant de
quel droit ils nous tuent toi
si vous aussi cette phrase vous outre
agissez moment de signer ma pétition
j'ai déjà des milliards d'influenceurs
de renom qui ont rejoint ma cause
[Musique]
allez mobilisez vous
ac à tous ceux qui me soutiennent sur
you keep et une pensée émue à jean paul
héger net qui sont malheureusement
encore de ce monde
[Musique]